foreign
[Music]
a couple years ago in southern Italy the
police were spying on an organized crime
Network
we are undercover footage shows these
large tanker trucks passing into their
compound they started tracking these
trucks with GPS and found that the
trucks were loaded with oil they were
delivering this oil to markets and
restaurants in Germany they were selling
it to buyers who thought that they were
buying high quality extra virgin olive
oil from the best Olive regions in the
world
yeah
after many months of this investigation
the police finally busted into the
compound and what they found is that
these criminals were importing cheap
seed oil that cost them just over one
euro per liter but then they were
coloring it with like chlorophyll to
make it look like olive oil they even
had the Machinery to bottle this oil and
to label it with the important words
extra virgin olive oil with a nice
little Italian flag on it at the height
of their operation they were selling
around 23 000 liters per week to
customers in the north for five to ten
times the cost that they bought this
cheap seed oil for the police estimated
that they were bringing in around 8
million euros a year in the end 24
people were arrested and 150 000 liters
of fake olive oil were seized in Italian
jalo
[Music]
good olive oil is really hard to make
it's delicate it's hard to ship across
the world but when you get the real
stuff extra virgin olive oil it's really
healthy and delicious and from the mafia
in southern Italy to mainstream olive
oil brands on your grocery store shelf
olive oil is full of Fraud and deception
in fact there's a chance that you've
never actually tasted extra virgin olive
oil even if you think you have so let me
show you how this happened and why it
even matters and how you can get in on
the real stuff real extra virgin olive
oil because I'm telling you when you do
when you taste this it's unlike any
substance on Earth
[Music]
thank you
I've been working out lately like I can
do 10 pull-ups which when I started this
journey like 10 months ago I could do
one now I can do ten and that's because
of co-pilot copilot is this platform
where you get paired up with a personal
fitness coach and you communicate with
that Fitness coach via a very
well-designed app my coach is named
Devin and he's great and I've told them
all about my goals I want to be able to
lift my body I want to just have a
workout that's approachable and not like
grueling and he designed a custom
workout step by step so every day when
it's time to work out I open up this app
I press Start workout it fires it up on
my watch and on my phone and I start
working I just follow the instructions
there's like video demonstrations of
each step so that it's Crystal Clear and
then it moves you on to the next
activity what this does is number one it
gives you a real person to stand
accountable to which is just so much
better than like a YouTube video that
you're like watching and no one else
knows that you're working out co-pilot
found that people are nine times more
likely to stick to a workout routine if
there's a real person that they have to
stand accountable to nine times which is
actually not that surprising it makes
sense number two it allows you to
customize a workout exactly to what you
want oh and at the end of every workout
I'm able to give feedback to my coach
Devin and be like hey Devin
um I think it was too easy today on the
arms can we make it harder and he the
next day has coded in a new workout that
is harder on the arms the other thing
this does is it takes away ambiguity
like I think the killer of motivation is
ambiguity like you're like so what do I
start with and with copilot you just
press a button and it tells you what to
start with which for me at like six in
the morning when I'm working out because
I need to to be happy
I don't want to think I just want to get
it done and co-pilot makes that happen
because of its very fancy app I try my
best to actually use the products that I
endorse here on this channel obviously
this is a business I need to sponsor
these videos so that we can make good
journalism but also like I've used this
for 10 months and I can vouch for it
it's a pretty dang good product so
there's a link in my description it is
go.myco-pilot.com Johnny Harris just
click the link it helps support this
channel but it also gives you 14 days
for free with your own personal Fitness
coach so that you can design your own
workout and have somebody just down
accountable to and make those workout
goals actually come true thank you
co-pilot for empowering me to do 10
pull-ups and for existing and for
sponsoring today's video let's get back
to our story about the mafia and olive
oil
[Music]
most olive oil in the world is made here
in these Sunny climates of the
Mediterranean thousands of years ago
people here figured out that juicing the
fruit of this ancient tree produces a
golden oil that is like magic they
adored this tree its branches were worn
by the goddess of peace or a Victorious
Olympian it was an olive branch that
told Noah that the flood was over over
the centuries it became a sacred tree
with a sacred fruit that produced a
sacred liquid
it was food it was medicine it was fuel
it was a cosmetic it was a key part of
religious rituals for people of the
Mediterranean for thousands of years
the rest of the world didn't know much
about this special oil until the 1960s
when an American doctor was conducting a
health study of over 13 000 middle-aged
men from seven countries he founded that
the people of Italy and Greece lived
longer and were generally healthier
despite being ravaged by War and poverty
he concluded that it must be because of
what they ate fish nuts vegetables and
of course copious amounts of olive oil
instead of butter
foreign
word spread to the rest of the world
that this Mediterranean diet was the way
to live longer and that olive oil was a
key ingredient it's the 70s and 80s and
everyone is talking about olive oil
major health headline here tonight and
it involves a very popular diet the
Mediterranean diet full of olive oil
olive oil olive oil extra virgin olive
oil what is the best olive oil olive oil
if you like between 1958 and 2019 Global
Production of olive oil tripled demand
in the United States exploded olive oil
is no longer a regional thing
by the 1990s this has become a huge
International Supply Chain serving
customers around the world who are
willing to pay to pay a lot more for
this extra virgin olive oil the stuff
that scientists was saying was an elixir
of Health and Longevity you can combine
what is beneficial for health to what is
really tasty and people of course they
are quick
to grasp the importance of combining
Goods foods with good health suddenly
these small olive oil operations in
rural parts of southern Italy have
international customers clamoring to get
in on their product so they start
selling their oil to middlemen who can
take it and sell it to a co-op the co-op
gets all the oil together and then sells
it to another Co-op who eventually sells
it to a company who bottles it and then
ships it to a far away country to be put
on grocery store shelves this complex
supply chain with all these middlemen
comes with a lot of opportunities for
people to take advantage of this
newfound love for this magical expensive
oil but to understand olive oil fraud
you first really have to understand the
magic of extra virgin olive oil
[Music]
every winter at farms around the
Mediterranean Farmers head to their
Groves to comb through the branches of
these ancient trees at just the right
time so that this delicate fruit is
perfectly ripe as it falls to the ground
carpeting The Grove floor the clock
immediately starts ticking within 24
hours they must get this precious fruit
to the mill where the olives are crushed
and then spun in a centrifuge until the
oil is separated
no heat no filters no chemicals nothing
just high quality olives quickly pressed
one time and spun then bottled then
crucially kept dark kept cool sealed and
ideally consumed within 18 months it's a
delicate resource intensive process to
pull this off and even more so when you
then have to ship it across the globe
but it's really the only way to get this
magical liquid that we call extra virgin
olive oil the stuff that's good for your
heart for your brain for your bones the
stuff that tastes like fatty grassy gold
this stuff is so good and this is where
I tell you that most olive oil is kind
of a lie sometimes a white lie and other
times a mafia is deceiving you kind of
lie so first things first Italian olive
oil is important here if you look at
this price graph of Italian olive oil
you'll see that it's quite a bit more
expensive than the olive oil coming from
the other big players in this space
Spain and Greece Italian olive oil is
more expensive not only because it is
known for genuine quality but also
because it's Italy Italy is Italy it
looks like this its food looks like this
Italy has the perception of being the
gourmet food epicenter of the world so
people including me are willing to pay
more for Italian extra virgin olive oil
because it's good and it's from Italy on
that point let me show you two kind of
insane Maps first look where most olive
oil is made in Italy it's the darker
areas down here and second let's look at
the regions of Italy where the mafia is
most present right down here now next to
this toe and the heel of the boot the
regions with the highest production of
olive oil are the regions where the
mafia is and this is where it all comes
together there's this ancient trading
city right on the toe of the boot
the calabrian Mafia One of Italy's most
influential Clans controls this busy
port in the city
they also control or influence much of
the Farmland in this area including
Olive Groves in 2016 this Mafia Clan was
shipping in cheap low-grade chemically
treated olive oil called pumice they
would then bottle this up and label it
as Extra Virgin Olive Oil from Italy
even though it was like a derivative of
olive oil chemically treated and not
from Italy but then they would ship this
olive oil to importers in New York City
in Boston in Chicago importers who
thought they were buying the best olive
oil in the world from the best region in
the world but really they were paying
for cheap oil and giving huge profit
margins to the mafia committing this
fraud the Italian food police which is
like literally a thing eventually busted
this scheme the arrest of one of the
most powerful street gangs in Calabria
olive oil is hard to detect as fake it
kind of all looks the same you have to
have a trained eye to know if like the
color is off most people aren't drinking
olive oil
they're cooking with it or putting it on
their salad and they're kind of just
assuming that it's legitimate and that
it's giving them health benefits and a
lot of people don't really know what
good olive oil tastes like so olive oil
fraud is particularly easy and
particularly lucrative because of the
premium price that good extra virgin
olive oil commands because of this Italy
has an entire investigative unit
dedicated to food fraud and they're
regularly busting these fraud schemes
some of them are less extreme than the
ones we've talked about a really common
one is people will ship in olive oil
from Spain they will bottle it in Italy
and then they will put a label that says
that it's Italian olive oil and they
will sell it at a higher premium because
Italian olive oil commands a higher
price but oftentimes it's even more
subtle than that olive oil companies
will mix Extra Virgin Olive Oil with old
or decaying oil or they'll use olives
that have been sitting on the floor of
the Grove for like a couple of weeks and
they're like you know we'll just like
press them anyway and call it extra
virgin olive oil and it's not it's a
different thing again this is a really
complex supply chain with lots of
opportunities for people to step in and
change it from this delicate liquid
called extra virgin olive oil to
something else and it's really hard to
detect a lot of this olive oil ends up
on your Supermarket Shelf with a photo
of a humble Italian farmer in an idyllic
landscape with words like cold pressed
or Premium Selection with pretend stamps
of approval that don't mean anything I
mean listen these could all be legit
extra virgin olive oils but I don't know
because here in the U.S we actually have
no enforcement standards luckily
scientists have tested this
one of the first big tests on this was
from researchers at UC Davis a college
in California they went out and bought a
bunch of olive oil from stores in
California they tested them to see if
they met the standards for extra virgin
olive oil and they found that 69 of
imported olive oil that was claiming to
be extra virgin failed to meet the
internationally recognized sensory
standards where an expert tastes it and
can tell if it's actually extra virgin
or not and of those 31 percent failed to
meet the chemical standards meaning they
were too acidic a lot of this stuff is
not extra virgin olive oil now I'm sure
I'm going to get an email from people in
the olive oil industry saying that this
study isn't actually legit because it
was only a sample size of olive oil in
stores in California but this was
actually just one of several studies
over the years that have shown the same
thing most of the olive oil on our
shelves claiming to be that amazing
golden liquid that is delicately
produced and stored and contains the
fullness of the taste and the health
benefits of Olives AKA extra virgin
olive oil most of these labels are lying
now most of the oil in these bottles
does come from olives like there's not a
lot of that fraud where they're like
taking seed oil and pretending that it's
olive oil that's been clamped down on it
still happens but not very often but
again it being made from olives is not
what makes extra virgin olive oil
special it is the way that it's made
it's the way that it's processed it's
how quickly they take the fruit from The
Grove and they press it and bottle it
and store it and ship it this oil is not
that it is not extra virgin anymore and
yet they slap a label so that you and I
feel like we're getting the best stuff
and we're getting it for a good price
you would be in big trouble if you got
caught labeling it as such in Italy and
a lot of European countries but wait why
haven't these companies who are doing it
in the United States gotten in trouble
because in America we don't care whereas
in Italy they literally have laws that
are violated when you label something as
extra virgin olive oil and it's not here
in the US we have no laws for this
companies don't have to test their olive
oil to prove that it's extra virgin they
can just import them and slap on extra
virgin to the label and no one can do
anything about it between this and the
fact that most Americans probably don't
know what extra virgin olive oil even
tastes like so they don't know what to
expect the U.S has become what one
expert calls The Dumping grounds for
olive oil that says it's extra virgin
and it's not
[Music]
so is there any hope here can you ever
try the real stuff extra virgin olive
oil that is like magical golden liquid
yes you can it exists you just need to
know what to look for we put together a
list of tips on how you can find
legitimate extra virgin olive oil and
know that you're getting the good stuff
I'm gonna put the link in the
description it's everything from the
material that the bottle is made out of
to the nuances in the packaging and
labeling and the date labeling the
quality seals we also give you some
ideas on some of the trickery that
companies try to fake it to try to make
it look legit but it's actually not so
that link is in the description if you
want to try extra virgin olive oil and
get your hands on it and are willing to
pay for it because spoiler alert it is
more expensive than the Fig stuff that's
pretending to be real then you can go
check out that Dock and hopefully it's
helpful the point is that it is possible
and I guess if you're still here
watching this video you're wondering why
is this so important important like why
are we talking about oil and well olive
oil fraud and there are a couple answers
number one is that this is a really
amazing old tradition it's a tradition
that fueled the civilizations in the
Mediterranean for thousands of years the
harvesting and pressing and bottling and
consumption of olive oil good olive oil
is an old delicate tradition and when
you mix capitalism with that
you often get a race to the bottom on
who can make it the cheapest and sell it
for the cheapest so they can make the
most money and inevitably you will get
opportunistic people
who try to trick you to make you think
that it's the real thing so that you'll
pay for it and this hurts the producers
who are actually doing the resource
intensive process of harvesting and
processing this in the right way and at
the end of the day to me it is
absolutely worth it good extra virgin
olive oil is unlike anything else a few
years ago I discovered that I had never
actually tasted extra virgin olive oil
so I bought my first bottle it was kind
of expensive it was like 25 and I
started using it on everything I even
started drinking it raw just to like get
the flavor because I'm kind of weird and
that's what I do and I'm sorry but it's
just delicious and I started to
understand why this stuff became so
sacred for so many cultures in the
Mediterranean why it's like a part of
every major religion why it is endured
as a health and culinary staple and I
guess in knowing how valuable this
liquid is I actually understand why
fraudsters and the mafia got involved
here why they tried to deceive us into
thinking that we are consuming the most
magical liquid on Earth
even if we're not
[Music]
thanks for watching the video
um am I too obsessed with olive oil is
that a thing because I'm I just really
like it and I just had to make this
video because I just am like I think
this video was me being obsessed with
olive oil and also me being so
frustrated at when the international
economy like screws us over with
um opportunistic corporations like those
two things coming together is what this
video is so thank you for watching I
hope you get in on the the how to buy
good olive oil dock that we put together
in the description I want to thank those
who support us over at The Newsroom
which is our patreon we obviously do
sponsorships for our videos which is a
major way that we're able to do these
but in addition The Newsroom has become
a community of people who want to
support the independent journalism we're
doing here and I'm deeply appreciative
of that over on The Newsroom you can get
access to a behind the scenes Vlog that
we do every month that introduces you to
the team shows you what we're up to how
we do what we we do just sort of gives
you a behind the scenes and then you
also get access to my scripts you get
access to Tom Fox music if you want but
more importantly you get access to the
warm fuzzy feeling that you are
supporting independent journalism on
YouTube
so I think that's why most people
subscribe to The Newsroom is because it
is supporting this kind of work other
ways you can support we've got Luts and
presets which are how we color our
videos and our photos I made a map
poster that I really like that's super
cool and fun and if you have purchased
it please
tag me on Instagram so you can show me
what it looks like in your room
um we launched a new channel that's
probably a huge thing I should have said
first search party is a new channel that
is live now we launched it with my old
colleague from Vox Sam Ellis the creator
of Vox Atlas he now has his own channel
and it is in collaboration with us and
we are all working together now and it's
awesome so search party is live I think
those are all the things I need to tell
you here in this little end part of the
video I'm looking forward to hearing
your thoughts and your comments I always
appreciate the back and forth and the
dialogue and the feedback so keep that
up and thank you co-pilot for for
sponsoring today's video
um thank you all for being here I'll see
you in the next one
foreign